(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
(bouncy, playful music)
- Whenever summer's come
in India, mango curry
is my favorite dish, which
I have to have to cook
and feed people.
- What I love about the curry
is that it's really fresh
and vibrant.
- The cool thing about using
the mangoes here is that
there's so many different
types of varieties.
- I've chosen to make a mango
caramel chili tart today.
I love mangoes and for me, mangoes
is essentially the beginning of summer.
I lived away from India for
a few years and every season,
my parents would send me mangoes
and that made me the happiest girl ever.
I remember opening my fridge
and just getting that whiff
of those fresh (mumbles)
from Bombay, you know,
Alphonso mangoes and I
decided to use them today.
My kitchen, we have this big conflict
because we're all pastry
chefs and everyone loves sweet
but there is a certain part
of it that hates sweets too
but they love chilis so
and I can't stand spice
just by itself so I decided,
"Let me just take that chili
"and put in the caramel," so we have a mix
of sweet, salty and the
tart gives it a nice crunch
so we have all different textures.
(upbeat electronic music)
- So here we have mango sticky rice.
Cool thing about using the mangoes here
is that there's so many
different varieties.
They all have their special attributes.
Some are super sweet,
some are super floral,
some are super citrus-y,
some are super acidic
and we just wanted to show
off a couple kinds of mangoes
and a couple of different things
that we could do with them
and give a different take and
sweet and savory mango dish,
only because a lot of
desserts, you'll see are,
they're very one note
so all of our desserts,
we tend to call them kitchen desserts.
They're not your typical
pastry-chef style.
They're always more about balance
so we'll always have a good amount of salt
through our desserts and a
lot of different textures
and temperatures and that sort of thing
so they're very different
from your standard desserts.
My working thought process
for dishes and stuff,
it's pretty random, a
lot of times I'll wake up
at like three, four, five in the morning
and then I'll just starting writing.
As soon as I get all these ideas down,
I'll come in as early as possible
and I'll actually make
the dish, dissect it,
make it again and it generally takes,
depending on the dish, it'll take anywhere
from 20, 30, 40 tries,
depending all on the dish.
(bouncy instrumental music)
- Mango curry is one of
my favorite mango dishes
where mango's used in a very unusual form,
which is to make a curry,
it's my grandma's recipe.
She comes from Rajasthan and
I have given it a chef's touch
by taking the Rajasthani
mango curry of my grandma
and giving it a south Indian touch.
The first time that I tasted this recipe
was at my grandma's
family, like her cousin's place
and the beautiful thing about using
mangoes in this season is that they
are nice, juicy, sweet, tangy.
The first time I made this
curry was without the pips.
I realized, "Okay, this is curry
"but there's no exciting mouth feel,"
and then I added the pips,
they just become fantastic
because you can pick them,
you can bite into them and
you get that wholesome feeling
that you have in a meal.
(energetic instrumental music)
- The dish we did today,
the cheeseling jamboree
with cheeselings, which are
those small puffed snacks
we all grew up eating, mixed with curry.
What I love about the curry
is that it's really fresh
and vibrant and it's also versatile.
You can use it a whole
bunch of applications
but in its best form, it's eaten raw
and in this particular dish,
it gives a lot of crunch
that stands in a contrast
with the salty taste of the cheeseling.
The inspiration for the
dish comes from our travels
across the country and
this particular dish
from col-pepper so eating
jamboree on the streets
of col-pepper what this one
with a slight nostalgic twist.
(playful electronic music)
- It's good. (laughs)